This old world is getting to me.
There's just no trust,
no tegridy,
so I loaded up the kids,
took my wife by the arm,
and I moved on out
to a Colorado farm.
Now it's early to bed,
early to rise.
The crops are plowed
and it's no surprise.
City folks are fighting,
and I don't give a darn,
darn, darn,
'cause I make my living
on a Colorado farm.
I gotta drive the tractor,
gotta cut the grass.
Chut-chut goes the baler,
like it's never gonna last.
There's food in the kitchen
and there's bud in the barn,
barn, barn.
That's life living
on a Colorado farm.
Ice cold beer, pickup truck,
country music, listing shit,
we got Tegridy
to keep us warm.
That's what you get
on a Colorado farm.
And I'm gonna stay
on a Colorado farm,
shit.